vous étiez hier soir tous les quatre
pour la fête de la musique peut-être
étiez-vous à l'elysée en tout cas si
c'était le cas voilà ce qui s'y passait
[Musique]
la musique électro sega je trouve ça un
peu répétitif mais moi 30 secondes ça me
va donc il y avait hier soir aux
platines un certain nombre de musiciens
très connus de cette musique
électronique dont dj qui disent mal
fils d'immigré noir est [ __ ] c'est pas
moi qui le dis je me permettrai pas mais
c'est écrit sur son tee shirt et donc il
y avait des danseurs qui sont des actifs
dans les réseaux lgbt queer vous avez vu
j'ai travaillé et donc été en maillot en
résille avec des mini shorts et qui donc
que ce se trémousser sur le parvis de
l'elysée est ce que c'est une bonne idée
valérie toranian de d'organiser ce genre
de fait
moi j'avoue que j'ai un peu fait le
rapprochement avec emmanuel macron
reprochant un lycéen de ne pas le être
suffisamment respectueux avec lui est ce
que c'est respectueux des lieux que de
faire ça moi j'ai fait le rapprochement
avec le carnaval c'est le carnaval à
l'époque médiévale
c'était le jour dans l'année où tous
inversé où on ne savait plus qui était
un homme qui était femme
les puissants devenait pauvres les
pauvres de nez puissant elle ne sait pas
qui faisait quoi et qui était qui et là
j'ai l'impression que cette fête du 21
juin de la musique c'est un peu devenu
ça c'est à dire tout d'un coup il ya une
possibilité de faire à la dans
l'enceinte de l'elysée faire venir des
gens qui après tout pourquoi pas la
musique techno electro c'est aussi une
réalité d'aujourd'hui
c'est au dix neuvième siècle la valse
était considéré comme un attentat à la
pudeur c'est à dire que on pouvait
considérer c'est vrai il a fallu du
temps et beaucoup de réticences pour
introduire dans des dans les soirées
bourgeoises et le tango après voilà donc
là chaque époque ses tabous et ses
danses obscènes que d'autres ne
supportent pas donc moi j'ai tendance à
beaucoup relativiser et dire voilà c'est
une fête c'est un moment particulier
n'allons pas chercher des
interprétations et des sous texte
dj a fait son oui c'est même pas un
comique parce qu'on sait ce qu il ne
masque pas ne le cache pas son compte
facebook
il faisait migrer noir et pdc lui qui le
dit il affirme on est dans une société
où tout le monde s'affirme sur son
compte twitter sur son compte instagram
sur la socio il le fait est une manière
de dire moi je suis moi et on est dans
une société comme ça donc
après tout c'est le reflet d'une époque
moi ça ne choque pas terriblement alors
on vous a posé la question sur twitter
transformer l'elysée en boîte de nuit
pour la fête de la musique
est ce une bonne idée 50% d'entre vous
considère que non ceux qui ont voté un
ca parts et sur le volontariat et puis
ce commentaire assez drôle de christophe
qui nous dit espérons qu'ils n'ont pas
cassé le nouveau service de table alors
assurez-vous que sur christophe je crois
qu'il n'a pas encore été livrée
heureusement que ça vous a choqué ou
vous trouviez sa maison de saint patrick
cette initiative
moi je trouve qu'en fait on est dans une
république yayi santé un régime qui du
coup qui m'ont faute de référence à la
république parce qu'en fait il s'inscrit
dans une tradition monarchique depuis
plusieurs siècles est obligé d'essayer
de se réinventer une assise et dans un
entre-deux où il a d'un côté
complètement ringard et de rires et
saint-just une autorité qui ne
fonctionne pas et avec des grandes
démonstrations de de poires et de
l'autre derrière essaye de compenser
pour essayer quand même de se raccrocher
parce qu on voit bien qu'ils aient une
incohérence dans le rapport symbolique
au pouvoir aujourd'hui après l'elysée
c'était un palais a toujours été un pas
les bourgeois où il y avait des grands
bals ou divine 19e siècle sous bonaparte
voilà j'ai dit rassure c'est un endroit
qui n'incarne rien donc il faudrait
s'interroger vous ne sait jamais rien de
passer historiquement parlant d'
intéressant moi si j'avais été macron et
si j'avais eu le bleu un moment la
grandeur qui se dit avoir jeu murray
interrogé sur un déplacement du pouvoir
et un investissement d'un lieu justement
qui ait du sens qu'il fasse un bol de
laquelle on n'aurait pas besoin de
s'agiter comme ça en faisant des trucs
qu'on essaie de montrer qu'on est de
gauche et de droite
d'un côté on fait des leçons de l'autre
on on fait venir des icônes lgbt qui
détestent macron pour de très bonnes
raisons par ailleurs c'est pour ça que
ce t-shirt et là c'est pas juste
gentille c'est une façon de marquer sa
différence et de montrer qui a pas
approbation par sa participation à cet
événement mais ce qu'il est contre la
loi asile immigration notamment
évidemment notamment et donc
donc là on est face à en fait on a enfin
pour moi le pouvoir de macron c'est un
pouvoir qui contrairement aux apparences
et un pouvoir chancelant parce qu'il ne
sait pas où aller on ne sait pas comment
réinventer en fait la fonction qu'il a
adoptée est il du coup ils n'arrivent
pas à donner une cohérence et il serait
dû à des artefacts de communication
comme seule détient déjà sur twitter
j'ai vu cette vidéo accompagnée de ce
message en reste on imaginer le général
de gaulle faire soit trois petits points
ça vous paraît une bonne remarque ou
après tout les temps changent mais comme
ça et comme ça a été rappelé ici le
palais de l'elysée a toujours servi à
des manifestations culturelles mais qui
était pratiqué en secret assez il n'y
avait pas de caméras à l'époque que un
jour par an il y ait une manifestation
culturelle en versements relatifs des
moeurs habituel dans ce dans ce palais
là avant moi et ça me choque pas j'y
vois quelque chose de relativement
réjouissant mais ce qui m'a choqué en
revanche je dois dire c'est que ça coûte
un pognon de dingue
la couverture de très intéressant
d'avoir le coup en effet oui on pourra
on pourrait avoir ce débat
non ce qui m'a choqué juste au niveau de
la forme c'est l'attitude d' emmanuel
macron par rapport à cette manifestation
là il ya un autre extrait il est monté
en haut des marches comme sur un
piédestal
il est il a déclamé à la foule présente
je suis très heureux de vous avoir
accueilli en ce lieu
j'ai cru relire la première scène de le
premier chapitre de gatsby le magnifique
vous savez apparaît comme un un espèce
de 1 magna qui recevait à lebon peut
laisser filer chez nous loin il est
passé lui il n'est pas roi ce lieu
appartient au peuple français elle est
propriété de l'état nation disait
brigitte et totalement déserté lyon ce
qui est complètement délirant brigitte
c'est un peu comme maintenant il veut se
reconstruire sa piscine au fort de
brégançon il ya un moment il faut qu'ils
aient reçu reviennent sur terre qui se
construit une piscine au touquet est
factice interroge un peu sur cette
appropriation de la république en train
de mettre en oeuvre alors le premier
quelques commentaires monique qui nous
dit non ça n'était pas respectueux cette
soirée
flora ago d'or on se lâche à l'elysée
mais on s'insurge quand un lycéen se
lâche en disant ça va manu et anti mac
qui nous dit le show de l'elysée était
consternant de médiocrité qui se
trouvait seul devant qu'est-ce que vous
êtes amateurs de musique électro moi je
suis toujours aventures des questions
vous mettez toujours à la fin de votre
émission et qui sont comme la vaisselle
de l'elysée et une fois où d'autres
apparemment anecdotique mais qui en
effet peuvent faire signe aux absences
de signer comme vous remercie
concrètement les pauses non mais c'est
vrai que les iem moi je m'interroge plus
ça peut quand même sur le message parce
que c'est pas n'importe quelle musique
et c'est pas n'importe quel groupe il ya
quand même je pense à un message là où
il veut affirmer quand même sa dimension
quand même moderne même postmoderne
envieraient post moderne avec justement
un groupe qui se revendique
oui nouveau monde avec un groupe qui se
revendique lgbt puisqu'il n'est pas
n'importe quel gbt qui est aussi
n'oublions pas que je m'étais de couleur
c'est très important ça n'est aux états
unis ce mouvement et il est incarné en
effet en france par kelly smile mais et
là aussi il ya un message peut-être
alors la question qu'on peut poser
peut-être plus sérieusement c'est est-ce
que ça c'est un signe par rapport à
l'idée de communauté ou communautarisme
et c'est le point d'interrogation
parce que c'est en effet une communauté
au sens vraiment américain du terme
est ce que ça dit quelque chose je peux
être trop loin mais c'est pas n'importe
quel c'est pas si vous voulez lgbt paris
si vous vous laissez passer
c'est vraiment peut-être alors
maintenant du point de vue musical en
effet je suis d'accord avec l'éditeur
annoncé aussi il ya un côté festival
veut tuer un peu d'accord avec tout le
monde je me demande simplement si y'a
pas derrière aussi quand même un petit
signe je dirais sociétale voilà oui et
c'est ali le président des riches et il
a ce paradera qui lui colle il a du mal
à faire
des réformes voie la plus à gauche et
plus sociale donc il est sûre le societa
pour essayer de faire passer l'idée qui
les peuplent et c'est là où ils se
trompent à mon avis parce que je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
du tout fasciné par ce que représente
les lgbt et c'est c'est là aussi qu'il
ya un petit je suis d'accord aussi il ya
un côté justin trudeau dans cette même
la faute de la façon de photographier
qui parle moderne de l'accordéon de
giscard mais l'accord est en version sti
batteur de la tendance c'est à dire
l'accordéon quand même revu et corrigé
par justement par le milieu gay c'est à
dire on avait affaire des spécialistes
effectivement de c2c sujet parce que
c'est vrai que il est en effet devenu
une icône absolument une icône de la
communauté gay saint jean paul gaultier
grâce à jean paul gaultier
si vous avez vraiment arrive autre sujet
christophe de voogd merci le quelques
derniers mots laissés aux internautes
monique qui nous dit combien va nous
coûter cette soirée alors apparemment
pas très cher parce que parce que les
les les chanteurs ou les dj pour comme
on les appelle les musiciens ont accepté
de d'avoir un très faible cachait pas ce
qu'elle nous dit ça n'est que de la com
et madeleine nous dit l'elysée était un
palais de luxure jadis pour
l'interrogation le spectacle auquel on a
assisté hier 2 démontre qu'il est
toujours bas côtés voilà c'était moi de
la faim en tout cas pour ce soir c'est
un point de vue et c'est pour ça qu'on
aime cette émission très bon week-end à
tous points de vue revient demain l'un
d'eux pas demain pardon mais lundi à la
même heure et au même endroit très bon
week-end
[Musique]